bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur Public
Sénat on est ensemble à 18h et 22h pour
donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
crise que nous traversons et justement
est-ce la fin des blocages agricoles les
syndicats majoritaires FNSEA et jeunes
agriculteurs ont appelé à suspendre le
mouvement après les dernières annonces
de Gabriel hatal est-ce au détriment de
nos ambitions envir ental on verra avec
nos experts que tout se joue aussi à
Bruxelles devenu ce soir l'épicentre de
la colère paysane et puis dans sens
public on vous propose régulièrement des
débats volontairement décalés de
l'actualité du jour direction l'équateur
ce soir où les cartels de la drogue font
régner la peur au
quotidien les gens ont peur ils ferment
tous les magasins aucun commerce n'est
ouvert de peur que les gangsters
viennent tout
pill
c'est vraiment effrayant les criminels
ne se soucient de rien ils foncent la
meilleure chose à faire c'est de les
éviter de se cacher on ne peut pas
s'opposer à des criminels bien
armés comment ce pays qui se rêvait en
petit paradis sud-américain est-il
devenu la plaque tournante des
narcotrafiquants comment l'État a-t-il
perdu le contrôle de certains
territoires et puis l'état d'urgence
décrété par le nouveau président peut-il
permettre de nettoyer le pays réponse
dans trois quart d'heure mais d'abord
les annonces du Premier ministre les
réactions des agriculteurs avec
Cécile ils appellent à lever les
barrages et à débloquer les autoroutes
mais cela ne veut pas dire que le
mouvement s'arrête les syndicats
d'agriculteurs satisfaits par la plupart
des annonces du Premier ministre estime
avoir été entendu mais reste vigilant
car disIl un certain nombre de points ne
sont pas au rendez-vous nous sommes au
moment où je parle avec deux situations
diamétralement opposé une écoute de la
part du Premier ministre pour essayer de
comprendre ce que sont nos enjeux dans
le même
temps nous nous interrogeons sur la
surdité de
l'Europe or ce combat de notre
agriculture notre combat à tous il est
intimement lié à l'avenir de ce qui se
passe en Europe parmi les annonces
développées en début d'après-midi par
Gabriel hatal un point de satisfaction
l'inscription de la souveraineté
alimentaire dans la loi nous voulons
être souverain souverain pour cultiver
souverain pour récolter souverain pour
nous alimenter c'est le premier
engagement que je prends ce matin nous
inscrirons l'objectif de souveraineté
dans la loi nous le ferons avec les
agriculteurs sur la base d'indicateurs
clairs définis avec eux nous
consacrerons dans le Code Rural
l'agriculture comme un intérêt
fondamental de la nation autre mesure
annoncée le déblocage de 150 millions
d'euros pour aider les éleveurs le
renforcement de la loi égalim elle
permet entre autres de protéger la
rémunération des agriculteurs Gabriel
Atal souhaite également faciliter les
successions enfin le Premier ministre
veut interdire l'importation de certains
produits traité avec des pesticides j'ai
décidé de prendre sans délis une clause
de sauvegarde sur le tcllopride qui
interdit enfin l'importation de fruits
et légumes traité avec ce pesticide que
nous avons interdit en Europe l'Europe
n'a à ce stade pas pris de mesures de
sauvegarde sur ce produit nous décidons
donc en France de le faire en avance de
phase au même moment Emmanuel Macron
présent au Conseil européen a demandé la
mise en place d'une force européenne de
contrôle sanitaire et agricole pour
éviter la concurrence déloyale entre
pays membres de l'Union européenne
Gabriel hatal obtient la levée des
blocages des agriculteurs mais à quel
prix est-ce au détriment de notre
ambition écologique on en débat avec
Emmanuel soufi bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes grand reporteur à l'OPS au
servir France Bruno cotres bonsoir et
bienvenue bonsoir politologue chercheur
au CNRS et au cévov Sylvain canne
bonsoir
bienvenue spécialist des questions
européennes professeur au Centre
d'histoire de de Sciences Po et vous
venez de publier avec Zoltan can un
article sur la colère des agriculteurs
européens pour la Fondation Jean jorè
Tam tranu bonsoir Tam bienvenueal
politique ce soir dans dans sens public
Emmanuel soufi je commence avec vous
qu'est-ce que vous retenez qu'est-ce qui
débloque la situation plus d'argent ce
mot souveraineté là que que promet
Gabriel Atal dans dans la loi oui parce
que c'est c'est un symbole fort c'est ça
ça engage en fait tout l'État dans le
respect de cette souverineté alimentaire
c'est une reconnaissance du métier de
son bien fondé du fait qu'il qu'il
travaille voilà dans le respect de
certaines normes donc c'est c'est quand
même une grande reconnaissance donc
c'est aussi quand même une victoire des
des Saica agricole qui s'était mobilisé
depuis le mois de depuis le mois
d'octobre et ça fait quand même 20 ans
qu'ils avaient un peu l'impression de
crier dans dans le
désert et et donc il y a une forme
d'écoute alors évidemment ça il y a une
conscience aussi du fait que bah c'est
pas les réponses ne sont pas uniquement
franco-françaises qu'elles sont à
Bruxelles ça explique aussi pourquoi ils
étaient aussi nombreux euh là-bas
aujourd'hui puisquil y avait le un
Conseil européen assez important et on
voit déjà il y a des choses qui bougent
quand même au niveau européen puisque
ils entendent cette cet excès de norme
qui qui était créé à chaque fois sur sur
tout on a entendu parler de de surdité
européenne mais on y reviendra
évidemment aussi en détail sur ce que
l'Europe peut veut faire ou ne pas faire
d'ailleurs en en la matière euh Bruno
cotrress euh la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont les premiers à
réagir conférence de presse c'est c'est
pas étonnant parce qu'on peut parler de
quoi d'une sorte de cogestion depuis des
décennies de la politique agricole
français c'est très clair que
l'agriculture française est gérée
effectivement par un système qui est un
système hybride ou un peu mixte où
l'état queogère d'une certaine manière
avec les organisations professionnelles
agricoles au premier titre évidemment la
FNSEA et toute la constellation de ces
organisations professionnelles qui
touchent de très nombreux secteurs de la
vie des
agriculteurs dimension social euh voilà
tout un tas de de de de dimensions une
époque on disait même d'une certaine
manière le Crédit Agricole la banque
faisait presque partie de ce système et
donc effectivement la FNSEA elle est par
nature dans une position qui est un peu
en porte à FAO quand il y a des
revendication si importante elle est en
même temps gestionnaire de ce de ce
système alors on a un acteur très
important il y a des éle sont aux
chambrre qui arrive et puis bah en même
temps elle doit montrer qu' l'écoute de
la base avec comme toute centrale un
petit peu dépassé voilà comme toute
centrale syndicale aujourd'hui depuis
plusieurs décennies le même enjeu qui
est la capacité à montrer queon arrive à
contingenter à être le porte-voie d'une
d'une d'une colère donc de très gros
enjeux effectivement pour ces syndicats
agricoles alors il évidemment une
question qui va revenir régulièrement de
notre débat c'est la question de
l'ambition environnementale de de la
France et et de l'Europe
syvin can on se souvient le c'était le
11 mai dernier uel Macron il parlait de
l'industrie des règles en matière
d'industrie mais il avait demandé une
pose dans la réglementation
environnementale européenne là ce soir
quand vous analysez ce qui est en train
de se passer à à Paris et à Bruxelles
c'est une pause côté français on
reparlera plus généralement de l'Europe
après mais côté français c'est c'est une
pause c'est un revirement comment vous
l'analysezvous ben disons il me semble
que ce qu'on peut comprendre enfin une
interprétation possible c'est il y a un
effort très important qui est fait
vis-à-vis des éleveurs ouis donc c'est
comme si il y avait la volonté du
gouvernement disons de s'intéresser
spécifiquement à une partie des
agriculteurs à une filière en
particulier les éleveurs c'est à la fois
la viande bovine ou ovine et la filière
laitière et c'est vrai que ces dernières
années les éleveurs ont sont but à
davantage de difficultés que les
cultivateurs on va dire voilà et
d'ailleurs c'est en écho avec le fait
que lorsque Gabriel Atal a fait ses
premières annonces la semaine dernière
il était en Occitanie sur le fameux
barrage de l'autoroute 69 et la grande
figure du moment c'est un éleveur donc
bon j'ai un peu l'impression enfin vous
allez me dire c'est peut-être une une
vue trop entre guillemets politicienne
faudrait voir ce que Bruno cotess en
pense mais j'ai peu l'impression que du
côté du gouvernement il y a un peu
l'idée qu'on va quand même essayer un
peu de de diviser le mouvement ou en
tout cas de jouer sur le fait que
l'agriculture et les agriculteurs en
France c'est un milieu très très
hétérogène très très divers ou et alors
vous avez pas tout à fait répondu à la
question sur le l'ambition européenne
est-ce que vous voyez là un décalage
entre le la finalement le alors moi je
dis virage mais peut-être que c'est un
peu fort français et l'ambition
européenne en matière environ sa oui
enfin comment dire le les AG agculteur
je crois souffre du fait que il y a des
choses très structurantes et très
structurées qui se décident à Bruxelles
depuis 1962 dans le cadre de la
politique agricole commune et que pour
schématiser ces choses cette politique
agricole commune européenne elle
concerne la production
et les États-membres ont fait le choix
puisque tout ce qui est tout ce qu'il
décid ensemble en Europe ils ont choisi
de le faire ensemble et tout ce qu'il
décid de continuer à faire au niveau
national ils ont décidé de le faire
ensemble enfin ils ont décidé ensemble
de cette répartition et on continue
encore aujourd'hui c'est pas dans la PAC
tout ce qui va du côté de
l'accompagnement donc la politique
budgétaire la fiscalité ce qui peut
soutenir la consommation la politique de
recherche et développement et cetera et
cetera ça ça reste du domaine national
alors effectivement donc il peut y avoir
un décalage alors que la pack pèse très
lourd dans le budget de l'Union il peut
y avoir ce
décalage dans les revenus des
agriculteurs elle pèse également très
lourd c'estàd qu'il y a quand même tout
un tas de secteur agricole ou de filière
s' avit pas la PAC il ils auraient pas
de revenu ou ou ou ou quasiment pas mais
par exemple s'agissant du bio ou du
soutien au verdissement de l'agriculture
on peut avoir le sentiment que les
gouvernements nationaux et en
particulier les gouvernements français
depuis 40 ans euh comment dire ne
soutiennent pas par les instruments qui
sont restés à leur disposition les
décisions qu'ils ont
coélaboré à Bruxelles et ça
effectivement je rejoins tout à fait ce
qu'a dit Bruno cotess c'est sans doute
en partie parce
que la la la corporation agricole et en
particulier le syndicat majoritaire où
les chambres de métier sont extrêmement
conservatrices sur le sujet alors on va
avoir une une première une réaction en
direct en duplexe celle de Quentin
lugillou qui est secrétaire général
adjoint des jeunes agriculteurs bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
peut-être un point de
d'organisation comment ça se passe sur
le terrain est-ce que les barrages sont
déjà en train d'être levés ça va prendre
du temps comment ça va se passer
là alors oui ça va prendre un petit peu
de temps parce que on va dire que ça a
été un petit peu
le grand grande mobilisation du jamais
vu depuis très longtemps donc oui il
faut que tout le monde déjà comprenne
toutes les revendications comprennent
vraiment tout ce qui vient d'être
expliqué donc on fait énormément de
téléphones en ce moment sur les points
de blocage pour savoir s'ils ont tous
bien compris voir si c'est bon pour eux
de leur côté et puis au fur à mesure les
blocages se libèrent donc je pense que
là de ce soir jusqu'à demain on va
encore avoir des blocages je pense dans
certains endroits pour la nuit notamment
autour du du du de Paris où encore des
blocages je pense vont rester sur la
nuit parce que il faut ranger replier
tout remettre tout le monde dans les
tracteur et retourner donc faut
s'organiser voilà les tracteurs on va
pas les lâcher comme ça du jour au
lendemain d'une heure à l'autre comme ça
non non il faut qu'il ça reparte t qu'on
voit proprement pour que tout le monde
soit en sécurité évidemment qu'est-ce
qui vous amène à lever les barrages
qu'est-ce qui dans le discours de
Gabriel hatal et de ces trois ministres
a formé une sorte de
déclic bah en fait depuis maintenant les
les 15 jours de mobilisation on a porté
toutes nos revendications on a eu
énormément de travail dessus on sent que
il y a eu des avancées il y en a où
aujourd'hui on nous dit il faut se
mettre au travail donc nous on appelle
plutôt à une pause de la mobilisation
c'est-à-dire on rentre chez nous on se
met au travail il va falloir aller
rencontre ès les préfets toutes les
préfectures dans les départements dans
les régions les ministères en compétence
des dossiers de manière à pouvoir
travailler avec eux négocier et puis
revenir avec un peut-être un premier
bilan au moment du Salon de
l'Agriculture parce que les agriculteurs
vont en avoir besoin mais on reste en
fait si on veut mobiliser mais mobiliser
ce ce coup-ci au travail en face à face
avec les rendez-vous et puis s'il faut
retourner au terrain parce que rien na
avancé après le sal de l'agriculture je
pense que les agriculteurs seront prêts
à retourner donc vous maintenez la
pression restez avec nous j'ai encore
plusieurs questions à à vous poser dans
dans un instant je vous propose
d'entendre une un extrait de la
conférence de presse de de Gabriel Attal
cet après-midi ce ce jeudi après-midi
alors il y a il y a beaucoup d'éléments
mais là c'est ça porte ça va nous ouvrir
un chapitre sur le l'usage des des
pesticides en en France et en Europe
Gabriel Atal qui dit vouloir lutter
contre la concurrence déloyale notamment
en interdisant les produits traités à
l'un des pesticides le chlor don
l'écoute nous devons mieux protéger
notre pays et nos agriculteurs avec de
vraies mesures miroires et des clauses
de sauvegarde très claires je vous
annonce donc que j'ai décidé de prendre
sans délai une clause de sauvegarde sur
le TCK lopride qui interdit enfin
l'importation de fruits et légumes
traité avec ce pesticide que nous avons
interdit en Europe l'Europe n'a à ce
stade pas pris de mesures de sauvegarde
sur ce produit nous décidons donc en
France de le faire en avance de phase
cet exemple c'est le signe de la
nouvelle politique qui sera la nôtre des
mesures miroir partout des clauses de
sauvegarde pour lutter sans relâche
contre la concurrence déloyales alors
c'est intéressant euh Emmanuel soufi
parce que il y a cette annonce mais il y
a aussi le le on va dire le climat
général ou le ton général des annonces
du du Premier ministre qui font que il y
a plusieurs associations écologistes qui
euh sont affichent communiquent sur leur
mécontentement ce soir notamment sur le
fait de mettre en pause le plan écofyo
de réduction de l'usage des pesticides
alors on est sur quelle ligne finalement
on est sur une ligne politique quand
même enfin puis on voit bien qu'en fait
c'est très compliqué de trouver le bon
équilibre entre la souveraineté agricole
et puis la transition écologique la
transition énergétique elle est
forcément douloureuse elle est forcément
coûteuse elle est forcément normative
aussi
donc enfin moi la semaine dernière
j'étais en xitadie dans dans le Tarne
c'est la région agricole la plus
importante en France c'est aussi la plus
pauvre ils vous disent tous quand même
qu'ils sont écolos dans la main euh un
cultivateur un paysan comme il se plaise
à s'appeler ainsi un paysan il a envie
de transmettre son exploitation à sa
famille ou un jeune agriculteur en bon
état saine avec des des sols propres des
sols sains il a pas envie de la polluer
mais en même temps c'est la l'excès de
norme l'inflation normative qui qui qui
les étrangle et puis sans doute aussi
l'absence de l'absence de financement
donc le plan écofito qui donc on fait
aussi une pose là-dessus on voit que
politiquement Europe Écologie Les vert
forcément marine Tondelier est
absolument mécontente Julien Baillou
pareil Olivier fort également bon là
c'est les des lignes de fracture he qui
se qui se dessinent à l'approche d'un
scrutin européen qui a lieu quand même
en juin où tout le monde est en train de
aussi de de faire passer ses messages
donc les agriculteurs on en fait passer
un maintenant que l'écologie politique
souhaite aussi ne pas être sacrifi
au nom du du de la sauvegarde et du bien
vivre quand on est agriculteur c'est
logique j'ai posé cette question à
quanttin Le Guillou qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que ce soir
on a le sentiment justement que
l'ambition écologique de la France a été
sacrifiée pour faire plaisir aux
agriculteurs c'est caricatural bah c'est
c'est c'est fort comme mot parce que en
fait ça fait quasiment alors moi moi je
m'occupe du dossier des dossiers
environnementaux pour jeunes
agriculteurs on a écrit chez jeun agric
un rapport d'orentation sur l'adaptation
au changement climatique euh qu'on a
porté dans les ministères qu'on a avancé
avec des mesures fortes pour palier les
changements climatiques avec des
modifications d'usage des produits
phytosanitaires là en fait sur le
problème de
l' de l'écho phito 2030 c'était on nous
demandait 50 % de phyo en moins d'ici
2030 euh sur un pas de temps où le temps
de voter le temps de application donc en
gros ça aurait été 1er janvier 2025
jusqu'en 2030 donc 50 % de phyo sur 5
ans en gros avec des cartographies
utilisées les unes sur les autres mal
mal dessiné où on a dit où est-ce que
vous tes aller chercher ces cartes là on
a voulu se mettre en avant pour dire
laissez-nous travailler avec vous il
faut qu'on regarde les cartes comment ça
fonctionne sur aussi ce qu'on appelle
les NODU les NODU c'est le tonnage de
produits phytosanitaires qui sont
achetés et vendus à tard et cetera où
aujourd'hui on était complètement en
désaccord sur sur la base de ces
chiffres là et sur leur utilisation donc
on a dit on leur a dit laissez-nous
tirer une chaise on s'assoit avec vous
on va travailler sur 50 % de phyo en
moins avec vous il y a pas de souci par
contre prévoyez mettre suffisamment
d'argent sur un pas de temps un tout
petit peu plus long quand même parce que
interdire les produits d'ici 5 ans sans
forcément ramener de solutions en face
euh c'est pas tenable donc travaillez
sur les solutions travaillons sur des
méthodes alternatives que ça soit sur du
biocontrôle que ça soit sur de la
nouvelle mécanisation sur des nouvelles
variétés mais on peut pas se dire on va
en 5 ans réparer les bêtises qu'on fait
depuis 20 30 40 ans voilà donc en fait
c'était ça encore qui venait pardessus
ok bien compris merci beaucoup Quentin
leillou je vous je vous libère merci
d'avoir participé et réagi en direct
dans ce sens public donc on comprend
bien cette cette logique on veut bien
garder l'objectif mais en allant moins
vite et avec un accompagnement Bruno cot
au-delà du monde agricole tiens ça ça
peut être intéressant de de de voir si
il y a alors je vais employer le
morotalbol vis-à-vis des contraintes
liées à la transformation
environnementale est-ce que ça s'exprime
dans quelle partie de l'opinion publique
en France c'est clair que ça s'exprime
dans de nombreuse partiese de l'opinion
ça c'est ça c'est certain je dirais
qu'au-delà même de ça c'estàd qu'au fond
tout le monde personne n'av naime avoir
des contraintes personne n'aime passer
son temps à remplir des des dossiers des
formulaires incompréhensibles c'est
clair mais au-delà même on va dire de de
de ça moi ce qui me frappe surtout c'est
l'extrême difficulté pour l'opinion de
décoder ce qui est en train de se passer
et de comprendre tout simplement ce qui
est en train de se passer sous nos yeux
au fond on a une sédimentation une
accumulation de mesures de crise où on a
le sentiment que on est devenu tellement
pragmatique dans l'action publique qu'il
y a pas de ligne directrice au fond on
fait une réforme des retraites alors que
l'opinion est largement contre on fait
une réforme sur les questions
d'immigration tout en disant mais on
sait que il y a plein de trucs qui vont
être sanctionnés parce que c'est pas
légal on appuie sur la transition
écologique et puis maintenant on a le
sentiment que si les agriculteurs c'étit
pas au fond mobilisés ben ça
passait voilà les mesures contre
lesquelles ils sont et donc on a un
extrême sentiment de confusion du point
de vue de l'opinion pour pour vraiment
essayer de de comprendre où est-ce qu'on
va et vers quel type de société on est
en train de nous conduire d'ici quelques
quelques années moi c'est surtout ça qui
me c'est surtout ça qui me marque et
c'est vrai que dans l'opinion se diffuse
c'est déjà là pas mal présent en France
mais se diffuse un peu cette idée qui
est d'une très grande confusion sur ce
qui est en train de se passer le
sentiment
que très très compliqué à mais bien sûr
mais on a le sentiment d'un exécutif qui
a un pompier qui court d'une crise à
l'autre mais mais alors qui qui sera qui
sera le prochain sur la liste donc voilà
un peu le sentiment que et ce qui me
frappe aussi c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
peut plus du tout dire qu'on est contre
l'environnement donc bien sûr que
Christian Lambert par exemple l'ex
présidente de de la FNSEA a dit il faut
pouvoir conjuguer les deux l'agriculture
l'environnement l'agriculture n'est
jamais l'ennemi de l'environnement mais
en même temps qu'est-ce qu'on a entendu
dire Gabriel hatal par exemple hier lors
de son discours de politique générale
c'est qu'il ne fallait pas que
l'écologie soit punitive c'est des mots
on les a entendu mais cétait il y a 15
ans donc moi j'ai quand même
l'impression que le logiciel de retour
en arrière il y a quand même des choses
on le voit présent et par exemple quand
on parle aussi bah de de de de l'accord
sur le le GNR bah finalement et bien
il y a plus cet accord mais il avait été
au départ signé par la FNS les grands
syndicats de l'agriculture il devait
être fléché vers la transition
écologique des agriculteurs donc quand
même dans tout ce qu'on est en train de
faire actuellement B bien sûr que
l'environnement est en train de passer
derrière et quand même en train de
passer après me semble-t-il oui mais
c'est pas ce que nous disait Quentin
leillou qui est resté qui est resté
d'ailleurs avec nous je vous r donne la
parole rapidement Quentin leillou vousz
réagir mais oui oui parce qu'en fait non
on n'est pas du tout en train de passer
après l'environnement il faut qu'on
travaille avec environnement sauf qu'il
faut qu'on les écoute un petit peu on
est quand même sur le terrain on est
quand même agriculteur donc on essaie de
prendre une place un petit peu de
discussion autour de choses finalement
on nous dit non on nous met des brides
et on nous sert donc le le le GNR ramené
sur l'environnement non le GNR c'est
juste que en fait ça plaisait pas à
personne il fallait aller récupérer de
l'argent on s'est dit sur les poin ou
quoi que ce soit allez on va rechercher
de l'argent il y avait aucun eu retour
on nous a jamais parlé qu'il y avait de
l'argent qui allait être fléché vers
l'environnement euh donc c'était encore
une contrainte sans forc de solutions
derrière il y a des nouveaux carburants
qui sont en train de d'arriver sur les
marchés il y a des nouvelles méthodes
aujourd'hui pour remplacer les
carburants travaillons plutôt là-dessus
investissons plutôt là-dessus et le jour
où c'est prêt on pourra dire aux
agriculteurs on est prêt et là on y va
sauf qu'aujourd'hui rien n'est prêt peut
pas encore encore et se prendre tous les
jours ouais merci encore syvain can
c'est une question je disais l'équation
elle est compliqué c'estàd que on aurait
dû prendre ce virage il y a 10 ans tout
le monde est d'accord pour pour le dire
et et et donc aujourd'hui le le coût
social de la transition écologique on se
rend compte que alors là c'est les
agriculteurs mais c'est vrai dans
d'autres secteurs il est il est quand
même compliqué à payer l'acceptabilité
du virage elle est compliqué à faire
passer peut-être d'autant plus quand on
a ce sentiment que les décisions sont
prises à Bruxelles qui est d'une façon
facile peut-être en France plus que dans
d'autres pays européens et souvent
montrer du doigt le Bou mississèire
facile mais prenons un
exemple la possibilité d'acquérir un
véhicule électrique en leasing pour 100
€ par mois voilà voilà une mesure don on
croit comprendre que elle trouve sa
cible elle fonctionne et c'est un très
bon
exemple il a été
question ces derniers temps puis ça a
été abandonné par la majorité
gouvernementale de faire des chèqus
alimentaires pour soutenir
la consommation de produits
bio c'est un peu la même idée on est
dans Comment on
flèé de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat une très bonne idéetait parce que
c'était trop cher est-ce que c'est parce
que ça touchait pas entre guillemets la
bonne clientèle électorale
mettrero ce type de
mesure elles existent très
ponctuellement
ou mais c'est dans ce sens là qu'on peut
imaginer d'aller c'estàdire que en même
temps qu'on demande aux agriculteurs de
comme on le dit communément de verdir
leur production prenons la loi etgalim
encore un exemple concret on va en
parler un peu plus tard
de il y a il y a l'obligation pour la
restauration collective de passer à 50 %
en bio c'est c'est une très bonne
incitation et ça marche toutes les
cantines un peu partout mais est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas soutenir d'une
manière ou d'une autre bah justement les
acteurs locaux qui vont qui sont obligés
de consommer du bio et qui donc le
payent un peu plus cher oui donc les
leviers ils existent mais ils sont dans
les capitales ils sont pas à Bruxelles
ok on on reste sur la la dimension
finalement politique de cette crise Tam
je me tourne vers vous parce que on a
alors aucun parti politique n' vouu se
fâcher avec les agriculteurs que chose
soit clairire ça c'est sûr ils sont
courtisés les agriculteurs dans cette
crise en ce moment c'est un peu le miel
et les abeilles Gabriel leur a criéon
déjà plusieurs fois ses preuves d'amour
he jusqu'à ce midi sur tous les tons
Jordane Bardella a écrit une lettre
ouverte enflammée où il écrit la France
vous aime jusqu'à même marine Tondelier
qui a rappelé opportunément qu'elle
était petite fille d'agriculteur et qui
leur a dit que les écologistes sont
leurs meilleurs alliés non il est loin
le temps de laagribaching les
agriculteurs sont dans le cœur de nos
politiques même si cet amour est sans
doute à sens unique mais donc pourquoi
tout le monde recherche le vote des
agriculteurs pourquoi alors qu'ils sont
de plus en plus âgés que leurs chiffres
ne de décroite ils sont aujourd'hui
autour de 400000 chefs d'exploitation
alors qu'ils étaient quat fois plus il y
a 40 ans c'est seulement 1,5 % de la
population active effectivement on se
demande pourquoi et bien c'est parce que
c'est une minorité électorale influente
parce que les agriculteurs ce ne sont
pas seulement les chefs d'exploitation
ce sont aussi les retraités de
l'agriculture ce sont les salariés de
ses exploitations ce sont les conjoints
qui partagent les mêmes préoccupation
c'est aussi un réseau institutionnel
très fort entre les Chambres
d'agriculture les caisses de crédit les
assurance agricole et enfin c'est même
une surreprésentation chez les élus
locaux 11 % des mères sont des
agriculteurs c'est le cas par exemple du
président de la FNSEA Arnaud Rousseau
maire de père en fils de son village de
250 âes Trossi en mulcien en saine et
mararne ajoutter à tout cela un
mouvement très soutenu par les Français
au moins au début hein 9 Français sur 10
les soutenz au début des blocages et
vous obtenez donc tous les ingrédients
pour que les politiques recherchent le
vote des agriculteurs et justement
comment votent-ils la première chose à
dire c'est que
ils votent plus que la moyenne on disait
autrefois que les agriculteurs allaient
au bureau de vote comme ils allaient à
l'église traditionnellement leur vote
pche pour la droite catholique modérée
on se rappelle la popularité de Jacques
Chirac alias mangait des pommes bien sûr
les agriculteurs ont été longtemps
pro-européens à l'époque des belles
heures de la pâqu ils étaient donc
allergiques au Front national de
Jean-Marie Le Pen enfin ça c'était
jusqu'en 2002 et alors comme le reste
des Français une digue à sauté alors
certain les voyent très proches d'Éric
Zemour lors de la campagne de 2022 les
voyait sensibles à ses odes à la
ruralité queenéni pas du tout pour plire
aux agriculteurs il faut connaître les
sujets techniques qui mèlent aides
européennes réglementation en tout genre
négociation annuelle des prix accord de
libre échange leur cœur a plutôt battu
par Emmanuel Macron lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle mais ça ne dit
absolument rien du prochain scrutin des
européennes bref leur vote n'est plus
acquis à personne il est plus divisé
qu'on l'imagine car vous l'avez dit il
n'y a plus rien de commun entre un grand
céréalier et par exemple un petit
producteur de lait et donc tout le monde
convoie de ce vote évidemment Bruno cot
dans la perspective des élections
européennes on a une idée de justement
comment les agriculteurs pourraient
pourrai voter même si on a compris grâce
à Tam que c'était hétérogène ça sera
plutôt centre centre droit c'est
habituellement effectivement le cœur du
comportement électoral des agriculteurs
c'est pas homogène il y a des variations
régionales qui sont importantes il y a
des tempéraments on va dire de ce point
de vue-l tout le monde monde n'est pas
non plus nexerce pas mais c'est
agriculteur de la même de la même
manière il y a donc des sensibilités
politiques qui vont au-delà mais on va
dire qu'en moyenne effectivement le
tempérament politique c'est clairement
un tempérament politique plutôt de droit
centre droit vous les avez étudié hein
les agriculteurs vous avez vraiment
travaillé de près cette question est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a une évolution
est-ce que ça a toujours été un
électorat plutôt centre centre droit ou
oui l'évolution vient en parler
effectivement ça a été à un moment donné
effectivement bien ils sont été
effectivement vers Emmanuel Macron une
partie d'ailleurs de la clientèle du
centre droit des seniors des catholiques
et c'est vrai que l'interaction
agriculteur senior catholique de ce
point de vue-là c'est assez assez assez
cohérent mais globalement c'est vrai
qu'il reste ils ont été une clientèle
électorale de ce qu'on ce qui a été
avant les républicains l'UMP le parti
Gauliste quand même très importante
pendant pendant très longtemps alors
encore une fois c'est pas parfaitement
homogène il y a des agriculteurs de
gauche il y a des agriculteurs qui ont
voté pour que des candidats de la gauche
bien évidemment il y a des différences
au niveau local voter pour les élections
municipales c'est pas la même chose que
voter pour les élections présidentielles
chez les agriculteurs voilà ça se situe
globalement dans cette orbite qui est
celui du centre centre droit avec une
interrogation qui concernait la la
Coordination Rurale comment va-t-elle
réagir syndicat qui qui qui n'est pas
majoritaire on va dire ça comme ça
comment all est-elle réagir aux annonces
du Premier ministre écouter l'un des
porte-parole du syndicat les gens qui
sont venus beaucoup sont fatigués
beaucoup sont partis depuis longtemps
ceux qui sont dans le 47 s doivent
repartir ils en ont pour de jours ils
vont rentrer samedi au dimanche et pour
nous l'agriculture la vie continue les
travau des champ sont là donc voilà on
va se donner on va se donner pour la
réflexion je pense que pour tout le
monde et en plus demain il y a le
président de la République qui doit
faire des des rencontres je dirais à
Bruxelles importantes donc on va laisser
un peu voir le dossier alors Bruxell on
va en reparler dans un instant mais
quand même un mot émanuel souffi sur la
la Coordination rurale qui a priori
était aussi en train de lever les les
les barrages qu'on dit idéologiquement
proche du rassem eMBLEMENT national même
si le syndicat s'en s'en défend est-ce
qu'il y avait des des arrièrepensées
politiques dans le côté un peu plus
jusqu'au boutiste de la Coordination
rurale dans ce dans ce mouvement alors
c'est un syndicat c'est quandme le
deuxème syndicat de la profession on met
on additionne la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs ça fait un donc derrière
vous avez la Coordination Rurale
d'itcr il s'affiche forcément à
politique comme toute centrale syndicale
après dans les faits le président Serge
bquet Cassagne son fils était quand même
plusieurs fois candidat sur les les
listes du Front national à l'époque
voilà et puis bah tout à l'heure ils se
sont rassemblés à plusieurs à
l'Assemblée nationale hein plusieurs
militants de la Coordination rurale à
l'Assemblée voulait rencontrer des
députés comme de par hasard ceux qui
sont sortis c'est quand même Sébastien
chunu du RN et et avec qui ils ont voilà
pu discuter
euh de façon de façon assez assez assez
poussé donc oui il y a il y a en tous
les cas le président de la la
Coordination rurale se dit que bah après
tout il a affirmé il y a pas il y a pas
longtemps je crois que c'était hier en
disant bah c'est une force politique
qu'on a pas essayé en France pourquoi
pas sielle est amême de répondre à nos
revendications trois petits points voilà
ok trois petits points tout est tout est
dans les trois petits points c'est
important on va parler donc de la
dimension européenne puisque en ce
moment même Conseil européen à à
Bruxelles je propose à J attend du PRI
de nous rejoindre puisque on le dit
depuis depuis plusieurs jours bonsoir
Jonathan c'est un mouvement européen
pourquoi les agriculteur européens
manifeste-t-il allez on fait le point
pays par pays avec vous voez alors ces
images que vous allez voir à Bruxelles
du jour ces tracteurs qui bloquent les
les autoroutes tous ces blocages en tout
genre les les feux de pneus et ben ces
18 derniers mois Thomas il y a pas moins
de 15 pays de l'Union européenne qui ont
assisté à ce à ce type de scène alors
pourquoi évidemment cette colère et bien
d'un pays à l'autre les éléments
déclencheurs de ces crises il varient
par exemple Pays-Bas Belgique Irlande
dans ces pays les les gouvernements ont
voulu réduire les émissions d'azote en
réduisant la taille des cheptel donc ça
ça a créé la colère en Roumanie en
Pologne c'est en un cas un peu différent
les agriculteurs ils se sont mobilisés
contre l'importation de céréal
ukrainienne c'est l'Ukraine c'est leur
voisin direct et outre Rin les
agricultur Allemands ils ont protesté
pour des raisons qui sont relativement
similaires aux raisons des Français
contre l'afflux de nouvelles normes
environnementales et notamment aussi
contre la fin d'un avantage fiscal sur
le gazol en 2026 écoutez cette
agricultrice il faut maintenir
l'avantage sur le diesel agricole c'est
un revenu supplémentaire pour nos
exploitations qui nous permet d'amortir
certains coût que nous supportons si ce
diesel agricole est supprimé nous ne
pourrons plus maintenir les
exploitations ce sera encore plus dur
pour les plus petite alors quel est le
le Tron commun de ces de ces
revendications il y en a pas mal
dominateur commun he partout en Europe
le mécontentement gronde avant toute
chose sur les salaires considérés comme
trop bas la concurrence aussi déloyale
vis-à-vis de la grande distribution et
aussi vis-à-vis des pays qui ne font pas
partie de l'Union européenne ou encore
ce fameux pacte vert européen dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler qui prévoit une
réduction drastique des pesticides euh
et il y a encore encore et toujoursin
des retards aussi de sur les versements
de la PAC ça ça cristallise beaucoup de
colère la fameuse politique agricole
commune dont la nouvelle mouture qui
date de janvier 2023 conditionne le
versement des aides à des objectifs
environnementaux et ça c'est un point de
de crispation dont a parlé encore hier
le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen
écoutez-le à ce sujet on peut pas avoir
une pâqu je le dis très simplement très
tranquillement très pacifiquement mais
qui se soit à ce point complexe et qui
se soit à ce point
incompréhensible tant pour parfois nos
administrations que pour nos
agriculteurs donc on a besoin de
s'engager résolument dans la voie de la
simplification vous avez des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui touche des
aides et qui ne savent pas flécher le
pourquoi il touchent des
aides donc on a besoin d'interroger
cette question et puis alors dernier
aspect intéressant Jonathan c'est que le
mouvement semble se calmer en France
mais dans d'autres pays européens c'est
c'est c'est c'est un peu l'inverse c'est
ça et et c'est reparti depuis hier assez
fortement du côté de nos voisins
portugais qui eux aussi sont rentrés
dans le dans la danse pour une
revalorisation de leur activité avec
aussi les Espagnols qui réclament un
assouplissement de la pâac et
face à cette bureaucratie qu'il juge
étouffante donc on voit Thomas le
malaise est quand même profond et assez
général en Europe merci Jonathan je
redonne des des chiffres sur ce que pèse
la politique agricole commune quand même
un pacb très lourd c'est 264 milliards
d'euros le tiers du budget de l'Union
européenne Sylvain Cann ça veut dire que
un packb comme ça on fait pas bouger
très très facilement là en ce moment au
Conseil européen il y a quelle marge de
manœuvre pour les pour les chefs d'État
est-ce qu'ils ne peuvent annoncer que
des décisions à la marge vous voyez ce
que je veux dire tout dépend ce qu'il
s'agit de modifier parce que si le
budget de la PAC est conséquent comme
vous venez de le rappeler ce budget a
pour finalité
de le revenu des agriculteurs alors ce
qui est souvent et à juste titre pointé
c'est que c'est de manière extrêmement
hou hérogène que ce soutien au revenu
des agriculteurs qui est financé par la
PAC bénéficie à ceci donc il y en a qui
touchent plus d'aide que d'autres mais
ce qui est certain c'est que même parmi
ceux qui touchent peu d'aide ou moins
d'aide il arrive parfois et même assez
souvent notamment pour les petits
exploitants ou pour les exploitants
laitiers que sans la PAC il n'aurait
aucun revenu du tout donc c'est toujours
pareil de quoi parle-t-on lorsqu'on
parle de la PAC lorsquon on parle des
normes ou par exemple là très
intéressant dans le
reportage lorsqu'on parle du fait que
les financement pack n'arrivve pas mais
les financements pack ils sont pas
versés par l'administration bruxelloise
directement aux exploitants agricoles il
passent par les pays c'est ça ils passe
par les pays ou par les régions quand
c'est un État fédéral et donc en
l'occurrence les retards dont il est
actuellement question ils sont
entièrement à la main des
administrations nationales ou régionales
je vais vous prendre un exemple qui est
relativement
c'était du temps de la majorité
précédente sous François Hollande et
Stéphane
Lefol les agriculteurs qui avaient été
encouragés à la fois par la pâac et par
un grand discours d'une majorité de
gauche à faire une conversion dans le
bio et l'objectif qui est d'ailleurs
toujours affiché c'est d'arriver en
France à 20 % d'agriculture bio et bien
il y en a un certain nombre qui ont été
étranglés du temps de Stéphane Lefol ou
qui ont dû faire un retour en arrière
parce que les aides bio qui venaient de
la PAC étaient bloqué par le gver par
l'administration française alors quand
ce dysfonctionnement a fini par être
sorti dans les médias le gouvernement
d'un seul coup les sommes ont été ver
oui il a dit ah bon mais on n'est pas au
courant c'est l'administration qu'est-ce
qui se passe et cetera il est très
probable que c'était lié au fait que
Bruno cotr se rappelait tout à l'heure
qu'il y a une forme de cogestion avec la
fnsoa la
fnsoa histor quement elle est pas du
tout favorable à la conversion au bio
et la dérogation sur sur la fiscalité
les agriculteurs ils ont raison
c'estàdire on peut pas en même temps
demander aux agriculteurs de faire un
énorme effort à la transition vers une
économie décarbonée en faisant du bio
c'est là qu' font leur effort les
agriculteurs hein puisque pas de
pesticides pas d'intran pas de chimie
pas de pétrole c'est ça que ça veut dire
plus d'heures de travail et cetera et
cetera coup il faut l'agriculture
devient plus mécanisée donc on peut pas
en même temps demander aux agriculteurs
de contribuer à la transition
énergétique en se convertissant au bio
et en même temps de de leur enlever
l'avantage fiscal qu'ils ont sur le sur
le gasoil dont ils ont justement besoin
encore plus parce qu'il passe au bio
donc voyez c'est PASC ou alors il
faudrait inventer des tracteur à moteur
électrique et comme on disait tout à
l'heure faire le leasing pour € par mois
vous pouvez acheter votre TR après la
motorisation électrique pour des pour
pour des engins lourds c'est pas l'idéal
mais mais ça c'est un are débat je qu'
nous rest pardon il nous reste 5 minutes
à peine et je voudrais quand même qu'on
entende Emmanuel Macron qui est à
Bruxelles et qui a également donné une
conférence de presse en fin d'après-midi
plusieurs annonces un contrôle des
importations de céréales ukrainiennes il
a il a rappelé que heureusement l'accord
sur le Mercosur n'avait pas été conclu
trop vite puisque pour l'instant il est
évid toujours au fond d'un d'un tiroir
et puis surtout il souhaite la formation
la création d'une force européenne de de
contrôle sanitaire regardez quand on a
une règle européenne qui est transposée
de la même manière partout entre nos
agriculteurs il faut qu'elle soit
contrôler de la même manière dans tous
les pays c'est pourquoi nous demandons
la mise en place d'une force européenne
de contrôle sanitaire et et agricole
force européenne qui puisse éviter
justement les la concurrence déloyale
qui peut exister au sein même les pays
parce qu'il y a trop de différen entre
la manière dont les textes sont
appliqués h et manel soufi il souhaite
en quelque sorte un égalisme européen on
pourrait on pourrait dire ça comme ça
est-ce que ça vous semble réaliste ça un
égalisme ou une douinee Européenne j'ai
plutôt envie de dire que c'est c'est la
peur du du gendarme la peur du contrôle
pour essayer de de de moraliser ce qui
doit l'être et en fait permettre en fait
à chacun d'être sur un pied d'égalité
c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est euh c'est
c'est des c'est des règles qui ne sont
pas forcément les mêmes d'un pays à
l'autre et donc ces règles grâce à via
l'importation arrivve sur le pays hein
c'est le le fameux pesticide que vous
citiez tout à l'heure sur les fruits et
légumes d'ailleurs c'était ti chloride
je m'étais trompé en en le citant mais
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il y
a une forme il y a encore une forme de
naïveté européenne en la matière
c'està-dire qu'on on continue d'importer
des produits
qui ne remplissent pas les même critères
avec des critères moins contraignants et
on les et on les vend moins cher sur le
mar sur le marché européen l'agriculture
elle est au centre de deux deux points
qui ne s'entendent pas c'est-à-dire où
il y a pas d'harmonie c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire la le respect
de l'environnement la transition
écologique et le pouvoir d'achat donc
tant qu'on aura une forte
inflation alimentaire parce que là
l'inflation elle a elle est à peu près à
3,1 % VO voilà donc elle elle reflue
légère enfin de façon importante he par
rapport au taux qu'on a pu connaître il
y a 2 ans mais malgré tout les prix sont
beaucoup plus élevés et ils vont rester
élevés les gens le savent donc vous avez
cette contrainte de pouvoir d'achat et
en fait l'arbitrage dans les ménages il
se fait pas sur le téléphone pas sur
l'ordinateur il se fait sur l'assiette
sur l'alimentaire et et eux les paysans
se retrouve en fait écartelé entre voilà
la l'importance de de de prendre soin de
son environnement et le pouvoir d'achat
là-dessus ils peuvent pas forcément
rivaliser et quand vous avez alors le
bio ils se convertissent mais je voulais
a ajouter un mal de déconversion aussi
pourquoi ils se déconvertissent voilà ça
c'est intéressant mais c'est que souvent
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont non marre
parce que c'est trop de tâes parce que
c'est trop de règles non c'est parce que
le prix du de lit de bio il est vendu
quasiment au prix conventionnel donc
quel est l'intérêt pour le paysan voilà
qui a ses vaches laitières qui sont
passés en bio au lieu de le vendre à 47
centimes il le vend à 43 et en
conventionnel et 42 d'ailleurs Bruno C
c'est a pas une forme d'hypocrisie
générale sur cette question de la
l'application de la loi égalime parce
que ça arrangeait un peu tout le monde
du gouvernement à nous hein au
consommateurs en pleine période
inflationniste que finalement B elle
soit pas totalement respecté que on
essaie de de limiter l'inflation ou de
tirer un peu les prix vers le bas bien
sûr et on voit à quel point tout ceci
raconte des histoires
incohérentes et l'extrême difficulté
pour le politique à à à mettre tout ça
dans un casadre
commun et à dire ce dont j'ai parlé il y
a 2 ans est cohérent avec ce que j'ai
dit ce que je dis aujourd'hui et là il y
a un souci je rappelle qu'il y a 2 ans
le président de la République a été élu
en nous disant qu'au lendemain de son
élection la transition climatique allait
irriguer l'intégralité des politiques
publiques que il nommerait à matigant
quelqu'un qui serait une sorte de tour
de contrôle de cette irrigation
généralisée du climat dans l'ensemble de
l'action publique lors son discours de
politique générale Gabriel a cité en
numéro 4 de des piliers des qu c'était
le 4e et on ne peut pas dire que c'était
le moment de son discours plus long non
c'est pas ce dont il a le plus parlé
dans son discours on est bien d'accord
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat et à bientôt
sur sur Public Sénat